David I'll start with you in the origins
of this movie
um how did the book come to you and how
quickly did you realize this was
something that might be in your in
Luca's wheelhouse uh it was submitted to
me by a producer I had never met
um and she had attempted a couple of
times to get it to me without success
and so went through my lawyer which is
an odd way to do it and
with a note that said I think this is
for you and I didn't know what that
meant until I read the book but I was so
happy but also confused that it was a
love story because I had not written one
before in my career
and I guess I understand why this
particular love story was maybe maybe
came my way but I was just
um particularly excited at the idea of a
story that was about two young people
seeing one another being seen by one
another in the context of so many
um
competing Dynamics both between
themselves within themselves with the
world and
sort of told through the grammar of a
kind of Road movie that's also a horror
film that's also a coming-of-age story
and
you know I was halfway through the book
and thought I know one person one
director I would trust to do this with
because Luke and I had had such a lovely
collaboration on a bigger Splash and so
I
yeah thank you so uh sent it his way and
um by the time there was a script uh
Luca had the bandwidth to actually read
it and and
moved on from there
and so Luca when you read the script
what was the thing you responded to
initially was it the love story was it
the the horror aspect was it the Road
movie aspect what what interested you
I think the first thing this that we had
a very struck a big note with me was the
great quality of the script itself the
what the wonderful writing of Dave which
was very inspiring and compelled me to
to Really immerse myself into delivery
into the read the characters were my
strong pool
like these characters that are
um living through these profound
loneliness and sense of Abandonment in
these against this incredible background
that the Midwest of America and and
there as they've said their quest for
being seen and and to see the other
um that was quite touching to me
yeah well you know obviously a movie
like this the casting is everything and
you know Taylor I thought you were just
fantastic in this movie and really uh
you know really pulled me in and you
know for you when you first read the
script what was your reaction I mean
what excited you about this were you
scared by it
um well I met Luca before I read the
script
um and I was just excited at the
prospect of being able to work with him
um and when I read it you know I of
course have never read anything like
this story before
um and I also really love these parts of
America and I just thought that it was a
magical combination Luca and the cast
and the story about this
strange girl who is you know questioning
whether she can be alive in a way that
is sustainable
on the Earth and
yeah it was a themes that I wanted to to
explore so I was just excited I wasn't
scared at all about the cannibalism I I
thought oh it's a interesting Avenue to
explore these feelings that's
interesting that you talked before you
read the script I mean Luca what did you
know I guess why did you want to talk
with her before giving her the script
well because she's a formidable actress
and I saw her in waves and I was struck
by her and when we spoke on this Zoom
the we had a very delightful
conversation which left more wanting
more more company more
you know acknowledgment of one another
and and
I had a very gut instinct that Taylor
Russell from from from from
Trace movie waves was the right fit and
when I met her online I felt like very
strongly about it and I was right
thanks
now Michael you're only in one scene of
this movie but your character is so
fully realized and so terrifying
um what kinds of conversations did you
have with Luca about this guy and how
did you approach him
uh he reminded me yesterday that I had
asked him a lot of questions
on the page it was
uh one thing but it didn't necessarily
tell you where they were from or much
about what their lives were outside of
this particular day in this occurrence
so I asked a million questions and any
opportunity that you know Luca may be
interested in having me do anything I'm
there so it's it was a thrill to sort of
find my way inside of the mind of who
this guy might be and David was so
amiable and fun to sort of help me ask
the kinds of questions that got me a
little closer to what I thought he might
be
but it was delightful and really fun and
and uh
yeah it was it was just that
so we talked about Michael's character
who's very creepy then you've got solely
the mark rylan's character who's
extremely terrifying and creepy and
obviously some of that comes from his
performance but a lot of it comes from
the music uh the music that accompanies
him is fantastic and Trenton Atticus I'm
sorry if you could talk a little bit
about how you scored those scenes with
the mark rylan's character
um the whole film
is anchored by an acoustic guitar
and that was is the Love Theme and it
appears in almost every other theme
um Sally is such an extraordinary
character and we had had the experience
of watching the film
a longer version
with no music at all and it almost
didn't need any
so it kind of became about
capturing
the essence I think Luca called it utter
perversion
and
with that guidance we set about starting
with an acoustic guitar
and there's some flutes
there's some blowing spittle in a
saxophone
that's um disorientating synthesizers
but I almost feel like when you pull
back the curtain on what the elements
are
it makes it less interesting
what we're trying to capture was the
essence of this person
and I feel like
well it seems like it worked and I think
that's
what music
good music really does it's not really
this bit or that bit it's like how do
you feel when you're watching it well in
in a broader sense I know that you guys
like to create a sort of Sonic landscape
for lack of a better word for each movie
you do that's very specific and Trent
for this movie what were the kind of
overall guiding principles for the score
as a whole
well when we first spoke with Luca
um on this project which we were excited
to be invited to participate in
um he was very clear that this is a
tragic love story and the focus of this
is this um
intimate journey of these
lost lonely characters finding each
other and trying to find potential
potentially finding some
hope in making the life for themselves
and he said maybe maybe that is um
maybe an acoustic guitar is the vehicle
that can provide a Melody for that
and that along with some other
key bits of information and this is
before a camera was picked up so we just
had the script and dialogue with Luca
I'm shooting it in an understated
fashion and it's going to be on film I
don't want the music to overpower the
film
um
and some very elegant phrases
that were that really clued us into what
we needed to focus on so the majority of
our initial work
was finding that that Landscapes
experimenting with an acoustic guitar to
see what we could come up with what to
set that guitar in to make it
interesting and feel right really
focused on the sense of um
these characters in their Journey
so it was a nice treat later when we got
around to Sully and we're hearing make
it as perverse this he needs to sound
like perversion to delve into that world
but I think the biggest moment for us
that we that we'll remember forever in
our careers is um
when we saw the first cut of the film
which is as Atticus said
four four and a half hours maybe
it was spellbinding and we got to see
what these guys brought to the table the
transformation from a page to picture
the humanity and the vulnerability and
the intense creepiness in various cases
of how these characters came to life
and it feeling like
that thing that Luca does he brings a
there's a Humanity to it there's a
there's a warmth and a natural just
something you know the choices of
shots and where the camera lingers
The Genius of what Taylor brought to the
character you know of just watching her
face be able to convey
just just really really made made us
feel um
very grateful to be a part of this and
very much informed okay this is what
this picture is and and it's very
exciting to be involved in
well I have to say as a fan of this
movie hearing that there's a four-hour
version you know I'd like to I would
like to see that I hope it comes in a
Blu-ray or something at some point what
uh what kind of things did you have to
take out to get it down to the two hours
and was that a difficult process for
either for David and Luca
uh the draft that Luca read was by
design a very long draft I think it was
almost 140 pages and my thought was that
we would cut it down together
and I was surprised when Lucas said he
wanted to shoot all of it
um and it and we did shoot all of it uh
with one or two exceptions and I think
those scenes that didn't end up in the
Final Cut of the film were really
helpful to build the sort of the actors
sort of vectors into it or to flesh out
certain dynamics that you do feel the
energy of in the scenes that are in the
Final Cut
um but you know as a road movie and I
took the Road movie
genre as the chief way of structuring
the film and of course a road trip has
lots of detours and a little bit of
torpor here and there and red herrings
and People You Meet once and don't
expect to meet again but sometimes you
do and and I think in that structure
like that it was it was relatively easy
to excise things because the whole shape
of the film was fairly tattered anyways
because it was mimicking a sort of a
structure of life that is fairly
tattered
do you have anything to add to that Luca
or well there were avenues that the
characters of Martinelli were getting
toward that I felt we felt that somehow
contradicted the purity of their love
story and that's where we almost easily
had to lose something that we loved very
much but
uh well I love this movie and I could
talk with you about it all night but I
see the light on we're out of time so
thank you so much everybody thank you
for coming and talking with me thank you